اذا نتحول مباشره لمتابعه جانب من كلمه
رئيسه البنك المركزي الاوروبي في البرلمان
الاوروبي حول الازمه المصرفيه الراعنه
انها ماساه حقيقيه في اوكرانيا
لشعبي اوكرانيا وفي وجه هذه الاعمال
الشنيعه فقد اظهر الشعب الاوكراني مرونه
وعزيمه عاليتين اقتبسا رئيس اسبق للبرلمان
الاوروبيه خازيماريه
والذي توفي للاسف قبل شهر وقال
ان المستقبل هو لمن هؤلاء المستعدين بدل
جهود الاصغاء الى اصوات الامل
وبصفتنا الاوروبيون يجب ان نستمع ان نستمر
بالاصغاء الى اصوات الامل من اوكرانيا
وندعم الشعب الاوكراني في كفاحهم من اجل
الحريه والديمقراطيه والسلام والقيام
الجوهريه التي تمثل اتحادنا بات جليا بان
التضامن وبشكل خاص في هذه الازمه يجعلنا
اكثر قوه ومرونه فيجب ان سمر برعايته
قدراته على التصرف معا وبشكل جماعي ولا
اثبت كفاءته وفعلته خلال العام الماضي لقد
تمكنا من تقليص اعتمادنا على انابيب الغاز
الروسيه بحوالي تمارين بالمئه واسعار
الغاز عاده الان الى مستويات اقل من التي
شهدناها قبل الغزو
الاسواق الحاليه وبعد ذلك ان تعقلوا لي
تقييمنا حول اقتصادي قبل ان نوضحها اخر
سياساتنا الماليه وقرارات اتخذناها في
الاسبوع الماضي ولكن اسمحوا لي ان اشير
انه في غير ضم هذه التطورات الاخيره من
انني ارحب بعمليه
من قبل السلطات السويسريه هذه الخطوات
الضروريه لاستعاده الظروف الاسواق
المعتدله وتحقيق الاستقرار
في الاسواق وعلينا نذكر باننا نراقب
التطورات السوق عن كتب ونحن مستعدون
للاستجابه عندما كنت ضروريا المحافظه على
استقرار الاسعار والاستقرار المالي في
منطقه اليورو
منطقه وقطع البنوك مرن
وفيها راس مال وسيوله قويا
وفي اي حادثه فان عده ادوات البنك المركزي
الاوروبي معدل بالكامل لتوفير الدعم
بالسيوله لمنطقه اليورو ومنظومتها الماليه
ان كان ذلك ضروريا وللمحافظه على الانتقال
السلس لسياسه الماليه
ما سالتها الان الى استشها اقتصاد منطقه
اليورو وسياساتها الماليه نشاطات منطقه
فيها ربع الاخير من 20 22 وفقا لاحصاءاتي
الاخيره
المخرجات كانت افضل بقليل ما توقعناه في
ديسمبر ولكن
الطلب المحلي والخاص انخفض بشكل النحاد
نسبه تضخم العاليه
والغموض وتضيق الظروف الماليه
قلصت الاستثمارات والاستهلاك الخاصه والخط
بحاله المئه وثلاثه فاصل سته بالمئه
الاقتصاديه الاستبيانات اوضحتنا في الشهر
الماضيه مع تقليص المخاوف حول اعزاء
الطاقه وزياده الاسعار هذه هي العوامل الى
الجانب الدعم المستمر من قبل السياسات
الماليه والمرونه المستمره لاسواق العمل
من المتوقع ان تدعم التعافي خلال الارباح
هذا العام القادما وبالتالي فان النمو
المتوقع العشرين 23 رجع ليصل الى واحد